[Music]
the design law which governs the family
have likewise on its side differences
within itself whose interrelationships
constitute the living process of its
actuality but among the three
relationships of husband and wife
parents and children brothers and
sisters the relationship of husband and
wife is in the first place the one in
which consciousness immediately
recognizes itself in another and in
which there is knowledge of this mutual
recognition because this self
recognition is a natural and not an
ethical one it is only a representation
an image of spirit not actually spirit
itself a representation or image however
has its actual existence and something
other than itself this relationship
therefore has its actual existence not
in itself but in the child and other
who's coming into existence is a
relationship and is also that in which
the relationship itself gradually passes
away and this alternation of successive
generations has its enduring basis in
the nation the dutiful reverence of
husband and wife towards each other is
thus mixed with a natural relation and
with feeling and the returning to self
of the relationship does not take place
within the relationship itself
similarly with the second relationship
the dutiful reverence of parents and
children towards one another that
appearance towards their children is
emotionally affected by the fact that
the objective reality of the
relationship does not exist in them but
in the children and by their witnessing
the development in the children of an
independent existence which they are
unable to take back again the
independent existence of the children
remains an alien reality a reality all
its own that of children towards parents
is emotionally affected conversely by
the fact that they derive their
existence from or have their essential
being in what is other than themselves
and passes away and by their attaining
independence and a self-consciousness of
their own only by being separated from
their source a separation in which the
source dries up
in this long paragraph 456 Hegel begins
outlining the dynamics of the family
which are really the dynamics if we want
to call them of the divine law the
reason I say dynamics here is because
Hegel insists at the beginning that what
happens when we're examining the divine
law and that what we're doing here is
phenomenologist is looking at how things
in fact do play themselves out is we
find that there are differences or
distinctions entre Sheeta right and then
interrelationships dealing between the
different people involved in the family
the different members of the family and
Hegel says that this is what provides it
with a living process of actuality it is
a point that's worth dwelling on when we
theorize about the family we often do so
in a rather static way as if we're
taking a snapshot of how things are set
out and we forget that the family itself
is an organization that exists in time
and on the existent time in two very
important ways it exists in time in in
the way that other things do where
there's there's you know cycles and
there's ups and downs and you know of
course there's there's changes that are
going to occur and then we can think
about it in terms of momentous changes
that are passing something on so when
Hegel for example a little bit later is
going to talk about generations and you
know what's happening between husband
and wife becoming parents and then
children and then this going on and on
and on he is talking about that sort of
temporarily we often tend to forget
about that and we think in terms of like
you know the past like my ancestors my
you know great-great-grandfather and we
forget that at one time they were they
were siblings or children or new parents
and
that gets kind of lost in in the picture
Hegel's trying to restore that here for
a given purpose to parse out what the
divine law is so he says among the three
relationships the ones that he's going
to talk about here husband and wife
parents and children brothers and
sisters
why is he focusing on on those well the
last one is the really interesting
choice and he's actually not going to
talk about that much in this paragraph
but in the paragraphs yet to come but
think about traditional theorizing from
a social perspective or an ethical
perspective about the family you might
think for example about what goes on in
Plato's works or particularly in
Aristotle's discussions or in in later
discussions so the husband and wife man
and woman come together as Aristotle
says we are pairing creatures even more
than we are political creatures right
there's there's a natural instinct as
well we'll talk about in just a moment
but something more happens in a way this
is taking us a little far afield but it
reminds me of something that you
somebody who drew quite a bit from Hegel
but also it was very interested in in
applying it within a psychoanalytic
perspective Jacques Lacan points out
something that he's not the originator
of but he really drives it home which is
that because we find ourselves drawn
into relationships with the other we
often get into them before we have any
idea of what exactly we're doing and we
have to kind of figure it out as we go
along
while these powerful motives are driving
us that we don't fully understand and
culture is telling us contradictory
messages and you know oftentimes you
know older people look back and say oh I
wish I would have known in my 20s what I
now know in my 40s in my 60s about
relationships or that sort of thing and
so there's an interesting
thing going on here with the
relationship in the formation of the
family at least you know the the
traditional family as we're thinking
about it now he says among these
relationships husband-and-wife parents
and children brothers and sisters the
relationship of husband and wife he's
going to talk about that one first he
says is in the first place the one in
which consciousness immediately
recognizes itself in another this is a
very important point one of the things
that we saw come up is key not just in
that particular phase but as part of
human nature is this desire this hunger
for recognition from the other which
also allows us to have recognition of
our ourselves we saw this come up in the
self consciousness section and back then
it led to a struggle to the death and
the master-slave dialectic were actually
past that in this point so don't read
the master-slave dialectic into this
that would actually be a terrible
mistake
not only from Hegel's perspective but
also from somebody who is kind of
following along Aristotle's perspective
right
Aristotle fault in politics book 1 the
barbarians that is the non Greeks for
not realizing that women and slaves are
two different distinct relations right
or types of people that you could of
course have women and men who are slaves
but you shouldn't treat women within the
context of the domestic relationship as
slaves and if you do you're an idiot
and that's why says the barbarian men
themselves are naturally slavish there's
there's when everything is reduced to
power dynamics of the sort between
master and slave you know despot ace the
word we get despotism from and do doulos
or do la then or delay rather then we're
facing the distinctively human in
any respect and certainly a facing what
a lot to be going on within the family
so Hagel says this is a place where
recognition can take place between the
woman and the man now the recognition
takes place in part because of their
roles here identifying no longer merely
as woman and man or male and female but
as wife and husband as existing in a
relationship with each other so he goes
on and he says there is not only does
one consciousness immediately recognize
itself in another there is knowledge of
this mutual recognition there's a little
bit of a play on words here ear tenon of
Honor candid so this is quite important
now he says because this self
recognition is a natural and not an
ethical one it is only a representation
an image of spirit not actually spirit
itself and you might say oh well that's
too bad well an image is still better
than nothing isn't it and it can lead us
to two-spirit so there's something going
on here that is really quite important
that is developing within the divine law
Hegel goes on and he says a
representation or an image has its
actual existence in something other than
itself so what is that
what is the thing in which it has its
existence it's not a society that grants
these roles husband wife and says all
right do these things right no it's
going to be in something else that
happens within the household put men and
women together in you know natural
circumstances that have been occurring
throughout the history of our species
and let the you know drives for for sex
whatever we think they're rooted in
whether we think it's rooted in pleasure
or reproduction or intimacy or some
other thing you know framed in terms of
the good what is the product of that I
mean employed
you're his product of that hopefully
children you you produce new human
beings and so he goes on and he says
this this representation has its actual
existence in something other than itself
this relationship has its actual
existence not in itself but in the child
and the other so we have a relationship
between two others male and female
husband and wife who are recognizing
each other hopefully within the
relationship and they produce another
other another who is in relation to them
more other than either one of them I
mean if you've ever been a first-time
parent you know just how other that
little lump of crying you know needy
flesh that we call babies actually is
and then you know this goes on for a
while you want to see a sort of the
whole range between beautiful you know
interested curious self giving and like
the worst forms of egoism available at
that point in time have it have a child
have a toddler and ask them about things
so there's there's a new thing on the
scene here and other who's coming into
existence is the relationship he says in
also is that in which the relationship
itself gradually passes away
having a child changes the structure of
a marriage having a second child changes
it yet more you know I'm not saying it's
just in terms of for example sexuality
and you know the common parent
complained that oh now once you have
kids you don't really get time I mean
you don't really if you have kids and
you take your parenting seriously you
find yourself without time and energy
for all sorts of things sex is actually
sort of down on on the list you may not
have the energy
and time to do all sorts of other things
that you probably would spend more time
on if you could and then you know all
these you know things about mutual
pleasure can take place much later now
that's not to say that all the
caricatures of marriage and
child-rearing are actually true on this
but there is a transformation that takes
place within a healthy family and
particularly once we have more kids once
you have children rather than just a
child so he goes on and he says this
alternation of successive generation has
its enduring basis in the nation they
just suggest that there he's not going
to follow up on that but this this
notion of generation following
generation here's where the culture the
the overarching culture does play a role
and we might say that family has really
got it together and that family over
there is dysfunctional and we do that
not just from the basis of our own
family but within a larger social matrix
now going on Hegel will tell us here
that the reverence of husband and wife
towards each other is mixed in with two
things with what he calls a natural
relation that is sexual desire right and
with feeling the fool feeling is not a
bad thing for Hegel but feeling is
always lower than force telling
representation which is always lower
than conceptual thinking McGriff right
so what is happening here is not
entirely ethical in part because it is
mixed in with you know just natural
instincts and feelings and and desires
along those lines so he says the return
into itself of the relationship does not
take place in the relationship itself
so whatever dynamic of you know
recognition is happening husband and
wife have it but they're also
going to have it through the children
but they're not actually going to get it
and there's kind of a a tragic situation
that again has to do with generations
here so he said there's a two-part
relationship in parents and children
it's asymmetrical right that the
attitude of parents towards their
children he says is emotionally affected
by the fact that the objective reality
of the relationship does not exist in
them that is in the husband and wife but
in the children the children are the
product of their relationship the
children are the sign that the
relationship has strength and you might
say well what about a childless marriage
then you know is that mean that it's no
good whatsoever well we might think of
other things that work as surrogates but
those surrogates themselves are not
going to be possessed of a subjectivity
you know so if you indeed have your your
marriage and what you're going to do is
you buy a boat and you go boating all
the time and you really spend a lot of
time polishing it I mean you can say her
about the boat as we do but that boat is
not a person what else could be similar
well you could have a spiritual
connection producing works that have a
genuine subjectivity to them together we
might talk about adoption Hegel doesn't
worry about that at this point he's
doing something a bit simpler but he
does pointing out he is pointing out
that the relationship of the parents
really is mediated through the the
children so it says by their witnessing
the development of the children of an
independent existence which they're
unable to take back again so parents get
together driven together have a
relationship children are the product of
it the meaning of their relationship in
large part turns to be now one involving
the children and once you've given it
out like Hegel saying you can't get it
back again children are like weed
gardens you never know what the hell is
going to come up with them I mean you
can
you read your baby books and buy all of
your your fancy preps to you know have
them listen to classical music in the
womb and then you know send them to the
right little schools and and you know
police their their behavior so they're
not getting these ideas and they are
getting these ideas and and all people
do go wild with this sort of stuff in
our culture right which is basically a
sign that those people have way too much
time on their hands and I've never
really worked through their own worry
about their their own relationship to
the ethical or they wouldn't be putting
so much stuff on their kids which will
often make them quite neurotic but the
kids can turn out totally different than
what you want I mean it's not to say
that if you if you model certain
behavior kids aren't going to pick that
up but all the things that we've looked
at in the past having to do with sort of
formation by by determinants and then
what it is that a free subjectivity is
able to do in adopting some of those and
in reinterpreting them this applies to
children and the process of maturation
every generation finds out that the next
generation coming after it didn't do
things according to plan on the other
side he says that of children towards
parents is emotionally affected
conversely by the fact that they derive
their existence from or have their
essential being and what is other than
themselves
nobody is a self-made person and we all
realize that we come from somebody else
and it's contingent and it's contingent
in a certain respect right because I
could have come I could have been born
from other people my parents didn't
necessarily have to get together any
more than yours did there's no like
overarching necessity running the whole
universe that made it so that this
person had to be in this place at this
time we can talk about causes but
there's there's nothing with a capital
and necessity right and yet there isn't
anyone else who would have been my
parents because it wouldn't have been me
that case right so there's a contingency
and necessity paradox here as well and
it says they they derive their existence
from and have their essential being in
what is other than themselves and passes
away the parents passed away and by
their attaining independence and a
self-consciousness of their own only by
being separated from their source a
separation in which the source dries up
this is the the other side of the
equation in order to attain independence
you do in fact on some level have to
break with mom and dad and become your
own person and make your own choices and
you could turn out that you wind up just
like mom or dad but in a certain respect
that's because part of you has has taken
that on and decided for that and it
could have been very different so that's
where Hegel ends notice what he hasn't
talked about here brother and sister
that comes in the next paragraph
both these relationships are confined
within the transition and the disparity
of the sides which are assigned to them
the relationship and it's unmixed form
is found however in that between brother
and sister they are the same blood which
has however in them reached a state of
rest and equilibrium therefore they do
not desire one another nor have they
given to or receive from one another
that's independent being for self on the
contrary they are free individuality in
regard to each other
consequently the feminine in the form of
the sister has the highest intuitive
awareness of what is ethical she does
not attain to consciousness of it or to
the objective existence of it because
the one of the family is an implicit
inner essence which is not exposed to
the daylight of consciousness but
remains an inner feeling and the divine
element that is exempt from an existence
in the real world
the woman is associated with Bolivians
household gods conatus and behold of
them both her Universal substance and
her particular individuality yet in such
a way that this relationship of her
individuality to them is at the same
time not the natural want of desire as a
daughter the woman must now see her
parents pass away with the natural
emotion and ethical resignation for it
is only at the cost of this relationship
that she can achieve that existence of
her own of which she is capable
thus in appearance she does not below
their own being for self in a positive
form the relationships of mother and
wife however are those of particular
individuals partly in the form of
something natural pertaining to desire
partly in the form of something negative
which sees in those relationships only
something evanescent and also again the
particular individual needs for that
very reason a contingent element which
can be replaced by another individual in
the ethical household it is not a
question of this particular husband this
particular child but simply of husband
and children generally the relationships
of the women are based of the woman are
based not on feeling but on the
universal the difference between the
ethical life of the woman and that of
the man consists just in this that in
her vocation as an individual and in her
pleasure her
interest is centered on the universal
and remains alien to the particularity
of desire whereas in the husband these
two sides are separated and since he
possesses as a citizen the self
conscious power of universality he
thereby acquires the right of desire and
at the same time preserves his freedom
in regard to it since then in this
relationship of the wife there is an
admixture of particularity her ethical
life is not pure but insofar as it is
ethical the particularity is a matter of
indifference and the wife is without the
moment of knowing herself and this
particular self and the other partner
the brother however is for the sister of
passive similar being in general the
recognition of herself and him is pure
and unmixed with any natural desire in
this relationship therefore the
indifference of the particularities and
the ethical contingency of the latter
are not present but the moment of the
individual self recognizing and being
recognized can here assert its right
because it is linked to the equilibrium
of the blood and is a relation devoid of
desire but also the brother is therefore
irreparable to the sister and her duty
towards him is the highest
here in paragraph
157 Hegel is going to now sketch out the
third relationship within the family the
dynamic of the law of the family or the
divine law and that is the relationship
between sister and brother there is a
few things to keep in mind as we work
through this long ish paragraph one is
that in the back of his mind the entire
time Hagel has the figure of Antigone
from the Greek play in his mind you're
going to see this at the very end where
he's talking about you know the loss of
the brother and what has to be done in
relationship to the brother the other
thing to keep in mind is that Hegel is
not one bit whatsoever denying the fact
that they're there sometimes is desire
between brother and sister and indeed
sometimes the transgression of you know
the the incest ban but what he's talking
about here is sort of the the
relationship as he conceives of it as
normally functioning and even as ideally
functioning in somebody like Antigone so
he goes on and he says the two
relationships that we looked at before
husband to wife parent to child
are confined within the transition and
disparity the sides which are assigned
to them then he says the relationship in
its unmixed form is found in that
between brother and sister they are the
same blood which has however in them as
he says reached a state of rest
ruha and equilibrium so they don't
desire each other they don't have the
type of desire then on the one hand
husband and wife have for each other nor
do they have the type of desire that
characterizes essentially like a desire
for more being between parent to child
and child to parent so he goes on and he
says they don't desire each other nor
have they given to or receive from one
another this independent being for self
on the contrary their freedom they are
free individuality in regard to
each other you could say that there
aren't the kind of family dynamic
metaphysical stakes that are found in
these other two relationships for the
brother and sister and now you might
pause and say Hinkel why is it brother
and sister why isn't it brother and
brother or just sibling and sibling and
Hagel has got his reasons for that some
of which are going to come clear in
other paragraphs but between brother and
sister there's a greater degree of
difference at least because there's
sexual difference I suppose is the
easiest way to put it this comes from
having different roles so he says now of
course Hagel here is you know little bit
rooted in his culture and you know going
back to ancient culture where there's
this a very essentialist view on gender
or sexuality you know so he's going to
talk about the woman you know existing
in this way so let's follow along with
with what he says so he tells us that
the feminine in the form of the sister
has the highest intuitive awareness of
what is ethical but she does not attain
to consciousness of it or to the
objective existence of it why is it
because she's a woman no because the law
of the family Hegel says is an implicit
interessant which is not exposed to the
daylight of consciousness but remains an
inner feeling and a divine element
exempt from an existence in the real
world we've already talked about this in
the previous paragraph this is something
that is characteristic both of the
family and of the divine law that it
somehow alludes evades escapes the
totality of the the ethical community
the folk the the shock you know the
people the the state now it's being
looked at as something that belongs
peculiarly to the sister
why so this has to do with the
traditional assignation of gender roles
the not only the sister but also the
wife you know in say you know
traditional Greek Roman you know later
on Western culture tended to keep women
can find in the home the domestic
setting right I mean we already see
somebody like Wollstonecraft a little
bit before Hegel saying this is this is
precisely the problem right you've
decided to assign to one sex the fact
that they have to take care of the home
and the best you're going to provide
them in terms of education is not a
public education but a domestic
education the men of course get to go
out and belong to the wider culture
participate in commerce participate more
fully in intellectual life participate
in politics right and that's what the
brother is going to get through more of
so Hegel talks here in terms of the
woman being associated with these
household God and Miller substitutes
here the pinnock eighths right and and
the pen on face were you know exactly
what we're talking about here household
gods came from the word for larger or
pantry you know where you're storing
your goods the pentose and you know
these are not other people's household
gods but those peculiar to your
household and so Hegel says she beholds
in them both her Universal substance and
a particular individuality yet in such a
way that this relationship of her
individuality to them is at the same
time not the natural one of desire
there's something as Hegel is going to
say more universal going on here then he
talks about the relationship between the
daughter and the parents and how the
daughter is attaining to something that
that's elevated again the ethical so he
says the woman must see her parents pass
away with the natural emotion and
ethical resignation why it's only at the
cost of this relationship
that she can achieve dat existence of
her own of which she is capable
so this doesn't necessarily have to be
the death - this can be the replacement
of roles you know you're you're within a
traditional household so there's an
extended family the mother gets old
the mother is no longer running the
household you know the daughter takes
over and now she has a sort of
independent and substantiality as an
independent being that she was lacking
before but only because her mother has
given way now this is actually a big
intergenerational problem isn't it that
often times parents struggle because
they don't want to give up that sort of
thing this is becoming more of a
pressing problem as you know life gets
extended further and further there's a
lot that could be could be reflected on
about this so she says in the parents
she does not behold their own being for
self in a positive form the
relationships of mother and wife which
are other options for the sister right
are as Hagel says those of particular
individuals partly in the form of
something natural pertaining to desire
wife right partly in the form of
something negative which sees in these
relationships only something evanescent
and again the particular individual is
for that very reason a contingent
element which can be replaced by another
individual at the very interesting
suggestion isn't it well you can replace
one person with another person where
then are we going to have the person the
sister being treated as an independent
being so here's where Hinkle said
something really interesting and when we
read this we might say I don't know if I
want that kind of household he talks
about the ethical household it's not a
question of this particular husband this
particular child but simply of husband
and children generally the relationship
to the
women are based not on feeling but the
universal so somebody would say for
example let's take a mother aspect right
now there's a natural affection
generally that parents feel towards
their children we talked about this
today and not only in terms of affection
but attachment and all sorts of other
interesting psychological phenomena and
Hegel is saying that's all nice that all
particular and contingent when you have
an ethical relationship with your child
you have a certain comport mentor to
your child not as that little Johnny or
Jenny or whatever but as a child per se
now this sounds very impersonal doesn't
it and and so we might say I'm not sure
I really like that I just in the family
Hegel's going somewhere with this though
she said the difference between the
ethical life of the woman and the man
consists in this in her vocation as an
individual and in her pleasure her
interest is centered on the universal
and remains alien to the particularity
of desire so there's a bifurcation
between pleasure and desire contingent
particular and the universal the ethical
over here within which there's a greater
deeper satisfaction in the husband he
says the two sides are separated why is
this because the husband goes out into
the larger social world
he possesses as a citizen that self
conscious power of universality he
thereby acquires the right of desire and
at the same time preserves his freedom
in relation to it so he goes on and he
says sent in this relationship of the
wife there's an admixture of
particularity her ethical life is not
pure but insofar as its ethical that
particularity becomes a matter of
indifference when the wife is without
the moment of knowing herself to this
particular self in the other partner so
he goes identifying a problem here
rather than sketching out how it ought
to be he's saying precisely because the
wife is confined to the domestics
and then has has the husband the male
you know core relative who himself is
able to do these things she is she's
either going to be related to him in
terms of particularity that is true love
pleasure desire all of these feelings or
perhaps jealousy or you know negative
feelings as well or she's going to be
related to him through the ethical in
which case she is not going to have her
individuality as a particular individual
a component of that she'll be treating
herself as a kind of universal person
and there's going to be something that's
not missing but what what would be
viewed is missing is stuck on the other
side you might say now why is the
relationship with the brother different
than this Hegel says that the brother is
for the sister of passive similar being
in general the recognition of herself in
him is pure and unmixed with any natural
desire there's no stakes of you know
parents and children or husband and wife
or any of those sorts of things she's
able to have a a more you might say more
free and objective relationship with him
as an individual person in which case
they're both able to be recognized they
were able to provide each other with
that honor Kenan that Hegel says that
we're all desiring and that's precisely
because he's not a husband not a father
definitely not her husband not her
father not her child either we should
probably put in there he could be
somebody else's husband and father this
leads to you know other dynamics but he
goes on he says so in this relationship
the indifference of the particularity
and the ethical contingency of the
ladder they're not present they're able
to be fully ethical with each other the
moment of the individual self
recognizing and being recognized can
here assert its right because it's
linked to the equilibrium of the blood
and is a relation devoid of desire the
loss of the brother hears
we're going to get to Antigone is
therefore irreparable to the sister and
her duty towards him is the highest why
is it the highest because in the
relationship to the living brother both
of them enjoy what it is that Hegel says
that we're really fundamentally after as
self-consciousness which is recognition
mutual recognition recognition of the
other by our self and recognition of our
self by the other and thereby
recognition of our self you know through
the other by our self and vice versa so
the loss of that is a greater loss
according to Hegel than the loss of a
parent or even the loss of a child